quase cai a leitura do carro e aí galera
que aceite meu canal tudo com vocês eu
estou ótimo principalmente porque neste
final de semana agora tem show em
petrolina pernambuco gol
adoro adoro e onde é que você pode
comprar seu ingresso no sg posto orla e
não vale o ingresso do river shopping
que é isso o relato a gente fazer uma
festa bonita e petrolina valeu galera eu
vou contar pra vocês olha só que beleza
eu fui assistir missão impossível cara a
cara vou te contar a verdade o filme
massa e foi missão impossível bem vindo
porque eu fui meu namorado está perto de
começar o filme ainda foi começar a se
maquiar quer dizer já era uma missão
impossível chegar no cinema a tempo a
etapa chamada gostou que o remake ajudar
uma cama namorada o filme bem no começo
e já começa com ele pendurado do lado de
fora do avião que é bem normal a família
tradicional brasileiro todo mundo fica
pendurado do lado de fora do avião é
melhor pra você sabe que eu sou fã de
rock o de rock de qualquer forma agora o
tom cruise no filme é ação do começo ao
fim
eu assisti o filme 3d morrendo de medo
de pegar na bala perdida sem saber o
filme 3d pegar na bala perdida morre na
hora só na minha filha morrer uns 8 a
placa para o crude é a cepa tema é bala
que são [__]
agora eu acho engraçado o tom cruise que
desvia de bala como quem desvia de
moscas e trabalha no topo isso ele faz
só assim dê tudo certo vamos embora a
página esse cara muito um lado e os
cinemas só assim até a mulher estava no
cinema uma mulher no filme uma moça que
a mulher é o cão ela foi mandada para
matar o cara bem importante lá eu toco
os viu que ele ama time rocha tiro e que
pra lá e pra cá tudo isso para recuperar
o pendrive meu deus do céu bedai do pen
drive 15 kodak lá de casa e 64 gb
a não perder qualquer um pen drive que
contém as conta ea senha do banco do as
contas que têm milhões bilhões alegada
aquele dinheiro quente não consegue
dizer não tivessem 0 1 milhão bitrate
bichos e como é que a mulher que é esse
pen drive para dar para um cabo e um
toco esquece pen drive para não dar cabo
da competição é o cão ela pega uma boca
a 15 cabo a carteira de moto
ia lavar ano nesta manhã a visita estava
com quem divide boston megapixels tom
cruise vai atrair a paz no final tocos
leva uma queda dessa moto ligada que
elas querem que faz assim ó de bosta
além daquelas que você olha o pessoal
ródão vai dizer tá desgraça meu deus do
céu matar tom cruise meu deus nunca vai
vetá-la o tom cruise to the other
tabuzinho aconteceu nada no mundo é o
cão eo pior que a mulher da mãe é tudo a
negociar mas o camelo em negação um
explosivo que é alta definição
periculosidade e pulseiras e jogará três
média distância e da água só de 2011
esse batom é o batom de alta
periculosidade que se colocar dentro de
um vagão de uma criança ele explode em 7
segundos e meu deus do céu tudo nessa
mulheres pode acabar se também histórica
abaixo não cabeça alta massa mesmo onde
tocou ainda pega essa gata del mal a mãe
de penélope não esquece a maria da penha
membros consegue pegar o bicho tão
crucial tom crone é por isso que eu digo
que o toco selton cruz se o turno foi o
tom cruise kek o seu tom cru é por isso
que o tom cruise existe o que se conclui
não existir se alguém a querer seu tom
cruise o que acontecer não ia conseguir
seu tom cruise porque só o tom cruz pode
ser o tom cruise numa tópico acabou da
pior que eu fico louco das esfoliação e
o saldo ficou se fosse o que fosse de
ação também é o índice cruz amor acabou
filme eu vou pra casa né
no filme de ação fico doido que foi na
cozinha ou assim ó eu vou deixar se você
quiser sei lá do cinema e conferir se
você tiver gostar desse vídeo que embora
quebrar o recorde de lá e todo mundo
explica que em golfe que é que gostei
aqui embaixo é muito importante ainda
gostei que você deixa o vídeo é um
incentivo meu trabalho vai lá no
facebook onde eu postei vídeo novos e
quer uma missão impossível
clique em curtir e marca seu amigo que
ainda não assistiu o filme e também os
que já assistiram para eles ver na minha
análise como foi o filme cachoeira é o
meu cd com toda a música que já possui
esse canal em primeiro na descrição do
vídeo muito obrigado a assistir via até
valeu galera é não é com um beijão e
falou